there we go I feel like I've given a
sort of similar talk to a lot of you
people before so hopefully it won't be
too boring so yeah so today I'm gonna be
talking about lifting they'll still
incest amontons ban programs or any
field so let me first start by just
telling you what a span program is so
this was mentioned in nabis talk
yesterday about how he sort of these
were sort of invented using the fusion
method so what does this fan program
well span program is just a matrix over
a field
okay so here's any matrix here's like a
matrix over every field okay so how
matrix so it's not just a matrix though
so attached to the rows of the matrix
we're going to attach boolean literals
so positive and negative and then expand
programs gonna be a computational device
for computing some boolean function so
how's it how does it do that well if I
give you a truth assignment to the
literals on the rows this will we sort
of pick out the rows which are
consistent with the boolean assignment
and then we check if they span the all
ones vector so in this example
everything is true so these rows would
be consistent with the input so just by
summing them up you can see that we were
retaining all the we're spanning the
input vector so we would accept so for a
second example you know if we had true
false false no this row is left out and
you know observe that you know I'm gonna
let you sort of add literals on multiple
rows like we can sort of reuse week we
can sort of reuse literals as many times
as we want and just for the sake of one
rejecting input you know if we have
false false false so if this is the only
vector that's consistent with my input
and it obviously doesn't span the all
ones vector so we wouldn't accept okay
so this me so I mean this is a pretty
elegant sort of program but it's a
little strange to think about what so
it's natural to wonder how they relate
to other circuit models that exist in
the literature so was introduced by car
inventor said in 93 and non monotone
span programs over say GFP turn out to
correspond to mod PL or in the case of
GF through this parity L right so that's
just a counting you know checking
whether or not a branching program has
like an odd number of accepting paths
but monotone spanned programs are
actually like a very interesting model
and the reason is that they use non
monotone operations to compute monotone
boolean functions right and because of
this it makes them sort of difficult to
deal with like sort of intractable
to deal with when you're trying to
lower bounds for them so and another
reason that monolith mammograms are
interesting is that they they sort of
have tight relations to cryptography in
the form of linear secret sharing scheme
so it turns out that the size of a
monotone span program computing some
boolean function is exactly the same as
the amount of information that needs to
be shared in a cryptographic object
called a linear secret sharing scheme so
proving lower bounds for these things
and understanding the complexity of them
is actually like a like sort of a very
natural task so here's sort of a picture
so this is kind of like an idea of how
like sort of the standard circuit models
sort of relate to span programs and here
are these inclusions I'm just talking
about monotone models right so in the
non monotone setting we actually know
that so
span programs can simulate directed
switching networks and also they're
simulated by circuits but in the
monotone setting this is basically the
best set of inclusions that we have so
most of these inclusions are fairly
trivial so if you're not familiar with
like a switching Network or directed
switching Network just think like a
branching program is just a measure of
space right yeah so how do we actually
so what sort of node for like lower
bounds for these things well lower
bounds for them actually seem to be
quite hard so a long sequence of works
in the 90s sort of ultimately led to
proving into the Omega login lower
bounds just for some monotone function
computable in NP oh it's the number of
rows I mean like we can always assume as
the number of rows just by like a you
know regular getting rid of the columns
that are linearly dependent yeah so yeah
so works in the nineties like led to
sort of into the log in lower bounds but
just for sort of some strange monotone
function in NP that was sort of like an
artifact of the method later a beam will
and binary were able to sort of take
these techniques and use them to give
actually this shouldn't be log in this
shouldn't route log n separations
between span programs over different
fields and all of these arguments were
sort of very direct and and ultimately
sort of very combinatorial like they
dealt with started looking at a span
program coming up with a combinatorial
object that sort of obstructed the
existence of a small span program and
then more or less directly constructing
that so a few years ago myself with Tony
and Steve we proved the first
exponential lower bounds but for but
only for Spain programs over the reals
okay and this was sort of a this was
sort of an important part of our
technique that the things had it had to
we could only work over the real field
and our lower bounds even worked for
some function in monotone P which
separated real monotone span programs
from say monotone circuits and we were
also able to sort of improve them to get
actually strongly exponential lower
bounds by which I mean like properly two
to the N right and these lower bounds
use ideas from like sort of lifting
theorems which is sort of this you know
I'm sure everybody in this room sort of
familiar with it is sort of this a new
well old but now like as a paradigm in a
communication complexity lower bounds
it's just been sort of very very
profitable in the last few years but
yeah so the main emphasis here is that
it still only work for real span
programs and it was kind of really
annoying because this was really just an
artifact of our technique and it wasn't
really clear how to fix them so we were
able sort of recently to actually sort
of extend this result to get lower
bounds for span programs over all fields
and in fact we were able to sort of
sharpen the result in a very nice way so
now we can sort of characterize the
monotone span program size over an
arbitrary field for certain structured
functions so here's the main theorem
that I'm going to talk about today so it
basically says the following so if I
give you an A if you give me an
unsatisfiable um CNF so it's just some
unsatisfiable CNF formula then there's
some monotone function which is which
you can construct from this CNF such
that the the monotone spanned program
size of the function over that field is
sort of tightly characterized up to the
X to the exponent by the no Stellan SATs
degree of refuting this formula okay so
so that all cells have to agree of
routing a thing so no spelling test is
just a I mean for us it's a it's a it's
a proof system in propositional proof
complexity for algebra for Christian I
guess it's a nice theorem in algebraic
geometry but so the nice thing about
this is that it's obviously quite
pleasant it sort of characterizes
exactly what we can do at least for
these particular structured functions
and in particular it allows us to sort
of appealed
like the huge literature on the still
intact lower bounds to actually obtain
good span program lower bounds it's a
minor point but is it like and choose
themselves of degree or what happens
when the degree is there
so when the degree is in we can actually
sharpen this even further if the degree
is like fada and you can actually make
us a constant so it so it is basically
and choose the no stone SATs degree yeah
yeah any other questions before I keep
going okay so for the people who are
familiar with lifting terms they should
look a lot like a lifting theorem and
that's because ultimately it is you know
what we're doing is we're lifting sort
of a the sort of strange part from the
normal living theorems is that the
normal lifting theorems are sort of
stated in the pure communication
complexity language and here I've sort
of eliminated that and I'm just talking
about proofs going directly to circuits
right but ultimately the the mechanics
at the end of the day ours is all the
intuition it just comes exactly from
from lifting theorems so let me just so
what can we actually get from no null
spell and test lower bounds well if you
start with something like the induction
principle which is a really fancy way of
just saying like the principle like the
following unsatisfiable formula where
you say x1 is true and then you know x1
implies X 2 X 2 implies X 3 and so on
until you get xn is actually false right
this thing is treating the unsatisfiable
it turns out that the no Stellan SATs
degree which i haven't told you what no
silence has exactly is yet but we'll see
it a bit later so it turns out that the
null still access degree of induction is
tightly theta log N and it turns out
that when you do this transformation
from an unsatisfiable formula to a
function you get just you just get an ST
connectivity on the other side and so
this tells us immediately that the
Montespan program of SD connectivity is
n to the log jam over so this separates
this actually provides a separation on
the previous slide so over in an online
phone case fun span programs kind of
course compute every court can do SD
connectivity so this is actually
separate this is a non monotone monotone
separation as well
if you take like the pedaling formulas
then the function you get is gin which
don't really I mean you can literally if
you don't know what gin is you can
literally think of it as just monotone
circuit evaluation I'm gonna give you a
monotone circuit and I plug in some
inputs and just evaluate what the output
is it turns out that the Millstone sets
degree the pedaling principle is tightly
characterized by a combinatorial measure
of the graph that reversible pedaling
number and so this tells us that there's
there's graphs with sort of very high
pedaling number so this gives
exponential lower bounds by just
plugging in any one of those graphs and
okay and finally if you start with a
sort of like a modular counting
principle which you can just think it
was like is like a CNF encoding of like
a system of unsatisfiable equations mod
p so you run it through the machine and
then what you're gonna get is some
function it's gonna be guaranteed to be
computed in NP at the time that we wrote
the paper like if you go back and look
at it we didn't really have a I mean
like I can tell you what the function is
but we didn't really have a really nice
characterization its function so now I
can now actually with an upcoming work
we can tell you what the nice function
is it's actually a it's a monotone
version of mod P set so what do I mean
by that well it's just so imagine the
following take all of the so imagine you
have like a fixed set of boolean
variables okay and then what you're
gonna do is you're gonna the input to
this problem is going to be a subset of
say mod mod P constraints on these
variables right so the more constraints
that I add the more unsatisfiable is
going to become right so then the
question is if I give you a collection
of constraints on these variables just
decide if it's unsatisfiable or not okay
so this is clearly a monotone function
it turns out that running it to this
machine this is exactly the function
that we're going to get on the other
side and sort of classic results you
would let us separate the null cell and
sets degree of over different fields
using this so if the characteristic of
the field is P then the month then the
counting principles have constant no
still at SATs degree and if the
characteristic is not equal to P then it
turns out it's actually linear so yeah
so this gives
sort of exponential separations between
span programs overall feels yes well not
in monotone P though you do get a
function in P that's right yeah so yeah
that's right yeah so this would yeah
yeah that's right so you get a monotone
function that's definitely in P but it's
not it turns out it's not in monotone P
okay so yeah is there any questions any
other questions about there sir the
results okay so yeah let me just take a
second years so these so this result
here sort of this new this new
understanding of what this function is
this is coming in an upcoming work
between me and Nika and Dmitry and
British so I think Micah's gonna talk
about a little bit later today so be
sure to go and see it there's some clear
some cool stuff there but yeah okay so
just in summary so you know we can now
kind of nicely characterize fan program
size in certain regimes we can sharpen
parameters and we also get some some
other results which of which is which
I'll talk about now so how does the
proof work well the main ideas is just
what I said a second ago really the
intuition is coming at the end of the
day from communication complexity so let
me just remind you about the but the the
car of a person game which we've all
seen probably many times like this for
this workshop even so if you start with
a any monotone boolean function we can
associate with it the following
communication problem right so alex gets
a 1 of the function Bob gets a zero of
the function and they want to find an
input such that Alice has a one there in
Bob as a zero there so this is
definitely going to occur if the
function is monotone so what does it
look like well the best picture that I
can give you is something like this so
all of these certificates for this
monotone boolean function form a
combinatorial rectangle in like the
cross product of the of the ones in the
zeroes of the function right so and you
know a common theme in complexity theory
of course is that the the complexity of
this search problem in different
communication models tends to
characterize the circuit complexity of
specifically the monotone circuit
complexity of F in the case of the
monotone carburetor sinking so a nice
fact which I'd actually like to sort of
advertise that it's it's sort of a
classic result but I think that
everybody should know it is that much on
cars were vigorous in games actually
like characterized search problems in
communication complexity so what do I
mean by that well if you start with sort
of any covering by rectangles so let's
just say this is like a cross product
two arbitrary sets right you can imagine
this is a communication problem where if
I have some you know covering by
rectangles Alice gets an input here and
Bob gets an input here and they just
want to output what rectangle they lie
in right this sort of characterizes a
you know communication search problems
with that are that have low
non-deterministic protocols right well
we can easily transform this into a
monotone a car for vendors in-game for
some monotone function some partial
monotone function so how do we do that
well if I pick a row here all I'm gonna
do is I'm just going to write down the
the rectangle set this input lies in
right so X here occurs in X 1 and X 2
and X 3 so we just writes down the Alice
will just write down the bit string
corresponding at that and on the other
hand Bob Bob will put down a 1 for the
rectangles he doesn't belong yet right
so Bob here lives in X 3 and X 4 so
he'll put two zeros there and then he'll
put a 1 for the rectangles he doesn't
align them right so now you can just see
that the place where they were they
intersect right well that's exactly a
solution to the monotone customer
Peterson game for these two inputs so in
this sense monotone curve interesting
into sort of complete for for search
problems in in in in communication
complexity and in some sense that the
study that's what that what this is
telling us is that the study of search
problems in communication complexity is
literally monotone circuit complexity
right it's like these are just the same
things sort of that make sense yeah ok
cool so okay
so how does this help us well here's the
here's the theorem we want to prove well
like what I haven't really told you how
to do is how am I going to go from this
unsatisfiable formula here it is some
boolean function
and the trick is to just utilize this
connection that I just sort of showed
you right so if I start with some
unsatisfiable CNF formula there's a
natural search problem associated with
it that's not really a communication
problem because you know it like
basically it's just I give you a give
you a you know some input to the formula
and then just ask you to tell me a
clause that's falsified by the formula
right but using the intuition from these
lifting theorems if I just imagine
replacing each of these variables with
some you know some nut some good
function G which has a bipartite int
input domain right then you can
naturally construct a communication
problem which which is just Alice gets
you know all like values for all the X
variables Bob gets all the values for
the Y variables they want to evaluate
you know G of X on every single
coordinate and then just plug it into
the search problem and find a clause so
I think since it's hopefully there's
nothing complicated going on here I'm
just doing a composition just plugging
in a G for every variable too to sort of
force this search problem to be a
communication problem so this is
definitely a search problem right so by
what I just showed you every search
problem in communication complexity
corresponds to some monotone boolean
function so all we have to argue is that
you know we like we want to get some
control over how many inputs the
function has right and of course with
monotone cars more vigorous in games the
the number of rectangles will go back
here the number of rectangles is just
the number of input variables so what we
really need to control is how good of a
non-deterministic protocol or how many
rectangles there are in a rectangle
covering of this circle problem it's not
hard to convince yourself actually that
as long as this as long as this this
unsatisfiable formula has bounded width
then the search problem can't have too
many rectangles
so that might actually bear like a
little bit more spelling you know so let
me just say it a little bit more
precisely so so like if we imagine this
as sort of being our communication
matrix after I do the composition so
Alice gets some string and X to the N
and Bob gets some string and Y to the N
right so you can ask okay well what are
the what are the objects that correspond
to all the outputs of this search
problem right it's not obvious that
they're going to be rectangles
necessarily right like it's not
necessarily the case that if that if I I
asked what are all the inputs that Alice
and Bob get that correspond that
falsified you know see one that's not
necessarily going to be a rectangle
right because it totally depends on the
on the definition of G right so you
might get some sort of wacky object
instead which corresponds to X 1 for X 2
you know you might get some sort of
wacky object right so in I in this
reduction I just showed you a second ago
it was really important that these that
this was actually a rectangle covering
like a good non-deterministic protocol
but if C is bounded with what we can
basically do is just sort of break this
up into rectangles in sort of a trivial
way like all you have to do is just
observe that if C is with K then that
means that there's at most K variables
for either of the players and any of the
certificates so that means that I can
just brute force over want all of the
player one of the players inputs right
and just say okay well they're right I'm
getting first so for every value to one
of the players inputs that's going to
give me one wrecked one less sort of sub
rectangle in here so we should so
normally if these were actually this
rectangles we just get C but we actually
managed to get like I see with the
parliment factor
we involve only a constant number of
variables no this can work with an
arbitrary number of variables yeah yeah
so even with even with polynomial e-mini
in in it's okay so what what about X is
not X to be an axis with just one that's
just what we have one out for that
simple yeah that's right
so ultimately like what we're gonna end
up doing is is translating
nullstellensatz lower bounds to span
program lower bounds right so we really
have to pay attention to what the inputs
are in both cases so Fornell spelling
sets the the the complexity measure that
we care like the number of inputs really
is how many clauses there are right like
in proof complexity we don't want to
measure the complexity in terms of how
big the formula is so this is exactly
related to the number of input variables
of the final function that I get up to a
polynomial factor in the number of
variables underlying it oh yeah sorry
I think I meant written in this should
probably be X to the K there yeah sorry
yeah actually you're right that's it
that's a type of it that's that should
be X to the K thank you yeah
because well brute-force over one of the
players inputs so that'll be X to the K
yeah but even if X is like polynomial
and M we're still happy yeah yeah
okay so this is sort of the way that
this is how we're going to get this this
actual monotone function so there's an
even nicer characterization of what you
can do here but yeah I'll leave that for
later so no yeah this should not be here
this should be it should actually be n
is like basically signs of X to the K
the size of C no no I mean like this
will be the number of very like
ultimately the null cell and SATs lower
bounds like will depend on both on both
of these things like the Nelson test
lower bounds we want them to be a
function of M but usually and usually M
is like a function of n itself so it
does ultimately have a dependence on n
but sort of those that's on a parameter
that we really care yeah yeah right
[Laughter]
okay yeah so why is it's good well okay
so there's one other complexity measure
that we're going to use to really get
the lower bound part of this
characterization and this is this nice
measure due to Raz Parral from the 90s
that we've been calling the ranked
measure so the idea of the right measure
is pretty simple so if you start with a
monotone boolean function and you have
you know you're sort of contramar
vigorous and matrix like you're your
matrix with your with your rectangles
describing how the function is working
so we can define the rank measure as
follows it's a following complexity
measure it's just take any matrix a that
you'd like and sort of imagine just make
like overlaying it on the cars movie for
syncing and then all you're measuring is
what the rank of a is versus the rank of
a restricted to any one of the sub
rectangles a is a F inverse 1 by F
inverse 0 matrix yep so yes so and so in
this picture we had an actual sort of
rectangle covering here
that was x1 x2 x3 and I don't know x4 so
I can just imagine putting in a field
entry and every single guy here right
and then all I'm measuring is the rank
of the total matrix divided by the rank
of any one of these sub matrices so it
turns out that this that this measure is
like a lower bound on nearly all of the
complexity measures that we care about
here so it's a lower bound on formula
size on switching network size for if
the field is the same it's a lower bound
on X on span programs over that same
field and it's also a lower bound on
comparator circuits which are sort of a
which just think of like sorting
networks basically just like converted
to a boolean circuit model so why be why
should this even be true I mean let me
just point out that it's sort of very
easy to see this for formulas size say
so if I have a if I had a tiling like a
formula in the communication world it's
going to give me a tiling of the
underlying matrix right the
monochromatic tiling so that's going to
give me a partition that tiling give me
a partition of a right so ultimately
what's gonna boil down to is the sub
activity of rank right if I just take
rank on both sides and then just rank a
sub additive then I can just take the
maximum rank and just drag it out all
right so that's gonna give me the number
of rectangles in my tiling yeah and then
yeah so this is sort of for our purposes
like the like the real complexity
measures that were going to focus on for
lower bounds so I sort of give you an
outline so I don't believe that any sort
of individual step in this proof is very
difficult but I think that there are a
lot of steps and it's complicated to
remember how everything wires together
so let me just sort of give you a sort
of a broad outline so the first step
that we're going to start up is that we
need this way of translating
nullstellensatz bounds into rank bounds
right and ultimately what this boils
down to is coming up with a way to
translate polynomial degree into matrix
rank right so this is sort of the the
central lemma that makes this entire
thing click it's sort of like it like a
clean way to lift polynomial to be 2
matrix rank over every field
so using this we can get the upper bound
sort of almost immediately from the
definition of a span program and all
stolen SATs from the we can then do a
lower bound separately using this rank
measure so I'm not but I'm not going to
get the lower bound directly in terms of
no still and stats right away I'm gonna
get the lower bound in terms of a
different complexity measure which I'm
gonna call like just the algebraic gap
which I'll explain that in a bit okay so
then finally the last step is just a
duality theorem that's showing that this
algebraic gap and the no Stellan sets
thing they're actually the same thing
all along so this is a this isn't this
is a new theorem from this work so the
prior lower bounds that we had for real
span programs we had basically this
theorem over the reals and for the
algebraic gap and we but we didn't have
a way to lift polynomial degree over
arbitrary fields right so this is sort
of the main new thing that makes this
whole thing tick and then the
characterization of the gap final still
in sets degree is another thing that we
figured out that sort of puts a nice
clean answer to everything okay so let
me talk about this sort of main is this
sort of main lemma here so what are we
going to do well it it's pretty simple
so if we start with a with any
polynomial which is going to be will
always the same things are multilinear
we're in a multi linear world here okay
and then for any good gadget okay which
I'll tell you what good means in a
second you can compose the gadget with
the polynomial just like we did before
with the with the unsatisfiable formula
and what you get at the end of the day
is a matrix right I've written P
composed with G to the N to just mean
the X to the end of the Y to the n
matrix where you just you know at the
point you just evaluate the gadget and
plug the values into the polynomial does
that make sense so it turns out that for
good for well-behaved gadgets you can
characterize what the rank of this
matrix is going to be in terms of the of
the degree of the underlying polynomial
so the rank of the matrix is just going
to be the sum over all the monomials
occurring in the polynomial of well we
have a we have some term raised to the
size of the monomial here right and this
this term right here is just that we can
just imagine this is like an X by Y
matrix over this
field right so it turns out the correct
value is actually like the rank of this
of this underlying gadget here so you
can see here that like the the the
monomials the set of monomials that
occur in the polynomial characterize the
rank of this matrix like we can just
sort of look at the spectrum of the
thing and just sort of tell you
immediately what the rank of the matrix
is going to be so an earlier result of
sure stuff from this pattern matrix
method paper gives it turns out like a
corollary of this result so he shows for
win over the reals and for a particular
gadget he gets exactly this expression
but he this rank is not the rank it's
just some parameter associated with the
gadget and it turns out that if you just
dig into his proof it's actually the the
parameter is just the rank of the gadget
if he treated as a matrix and now this
was actually part of the difficulty with
trying to generalize this thing was that
sure sauce proof only worked for the
reals and this like he actually went and
used analysis right and of court like a
singular value decomposition and things
like this and obviously that's not going
to work over a finite field so this was
sort of the main thing preventing us
from actually getting getting things to
work over over an arbitrary field so I'm
going to show you sort of a very simple
algebraic proof which will work over
every field ok so what's the idea well
the idea is to first just like look at
the structure of this matrix so what
does it look like let's let's take the
simplest case and let's imagine that
this polynomial it's just like a single
monomial okay so maybe it's like maybe I
three variables Zed ones at two ends at
three and the monomial has just said one
time Zed three okay so the matrix is
going to look something like this right
I'll range over all inputs and I'll just
multiply together you know the
substitution in by G okay well I'm gonna
just for the purpose of making the
expression nicer I can sort of space
this out and imagine that I'm also
plugging in X 2 and Y 2 right so that's
just like the indicator the indicator
one function well I mean this is just a
tensor product right this is just G eat
answered with one tinted with G okay so
this is this is well this is actually
like quite nice for us right because
matrix rank is we know is multiplicative
for tensor ring but of course it's not
additive
right so if I if P was not a single
monomial but instead of like a sum of
monomials then I would get a sum of me
sum of matrices of this form like a sum
of tensors right and if if rank was
additive then I could just add them up
and then I'd be happy because you know
it's definitely multiplicative but of
course it's not and then that tells us
exactly how we should define G we should
define G to make rank additive right so
okay well what is a good gadget well
it's just good if for every pair of
matrices with the same dimensions if I
can sir with one on one side and G on
the other side then it just makes rank
additive on the other side that make
sense and now once we have this it's
just like it's just a super
straightforward induction right so just
take your polynomial just factor out the
first variable and then just you know
inductively we know after I do the
composition I know it's going to have
this form right I can just take out the
ones in the G's and then just
inductively continue down so there you
go yeah okay so is that is that sort of
cleared everybody oh what's an example
good there's a simple one here's one so
just take the just take a quality and
remove one of the ones up a diagonal so
it's a little bit weird also sure stops
gadget is good because of course by
weight I just said a second ago so why
is this good well I mean it's actually
really easy to see this right like if
110 surd with a plus G 10 surd with B
well one 10 surd with a is just going to
look like a matrix of A's Jeet answered
with B is going to look like you know
B's on the diagonal so I'm gonna if I
add these up I get this matrix but then
you know this is obviously like the rank
of this is obviously the rank of a plus
the rank of B right after you do some
row and column manipulations
cool so this is actually interesting cuz
it so it's sort of an important point
here is that it like in order for this
to occur this is just like sort of an
aside it's clear that I'm gonna need G
to be ranked efficient it can't be a
full rank matrix right because if if G
is a full rank matrix then I can't get
like an A here like I can't like it
extract out a factor of a here so this
lifting theorem even though it works for
you know clearly constant size gadgets
right it it somehow like the gadgets are
somehow have to be special like they
they have to be a you know rank
efficient yeah you have the water zero
yeah yeah that's right sorry
particularly reason why why you have
that oh no I just did let's just one fit
some to fit on the slide oh you wanted
to get sweet I mean it's saying is that
you can this works with any number of
ones less yeah yeah yeah absolutely as
long as it's not like as long as it's
not the I if this was the identity
matrix then this any this equality
wouldn't hold that's what I was just
saying thanks Josh yeah like but this
manipulation this exact same
manipulation works for any size matrix
like this right well to by QE it would
work but you don't get into anything
interesting because the rank of G is one
right you just get the rank of a plus
the rank of B so you would still get the
lifting theorem but you know like in the
play to scroll back for a second in the
statement of it I would get you know the
sum of once so it would just be like the
number of monomials in the polynomial
yeah so yeah I mean I guess it's
interesting it would be like the
sparsity or something yeah oh yeah right
well actually okay well that's good then
this is a way of recovering that because
when you when you do and composition the
rank is the sparsity right so that's a
corollary of this
this timing of what kind of matrices
give you a good gadget yeah
so I don't love to have a like sort of a
nicer characterization of this so what I
can I mean like an easy thing to observe
is that if we don't work over at 0 1 but
we're cover minus 1 1 right which is
obviously fine you know I can still do
multi linear expansions of things any
matrix of like this form or maybe I
should use a like any matrix of like
this form C minus C would work right
that's just sort of trivial and this is
in fact the structure of sure Stiles
gadget it's the index gadget with the
negation of the index gadget below it
but I don't have like a nice like like a
nice structural characterization like
for the purpose of lower bounds we just
wanted like a constant size gadget and
this works beautifully so okay so let me
talk about this lower bound theorem then
so how much time do I have left
xx K okay well so the main stuff here is
we're gonna sort of prove like actually
prove the lifting theorem and if you
remember the the expression for the rank
measure it's basically immediate from
the thing I just showed you before so
all we need to show is that you know the
the the rank measures at least end to
the gap so I so I need I need to tell
you what this gap is okay what does that
mean well let me just show you by an
example so if I start with an
unsatisfiable CNF so here's like the
stupidest unsatisfiable CNF I could
think of right it's like saying that
like everything has to be false and also
something has to be true okay so
associated with every clause there's
like the certificate you know that
falsifies that Clause just like the
partial assignment will suffice only
that clause and now what the algebraic
gap complexity is is it's the minimum do
it's the so I take a multi linear
polynomial over the same set of
variables so God's easier I should have
put X's but that's fine so it's a multi
linear polynomial so the polymer is
gonna have degree in and what I'm gonna
measure is how much the polynomial
simplifies when I hit it with any one of
these restrictions so it's going to be
the maximum
between the degree of the polynomial
which is n and the maximum degree of
this polynomial after I hit it with any
one of these restrictions okay so this
is the Kappa this polynomial and then we
just call the gap complexity to be the
maximum over at any polynomial right so
it looks a little bit strange at first
but if you remember what the rank
measure looked like this should look a
lot like the log of the rank measure
right if you think of you know the
degree is being the rank and then like
the sub matrices corresponding to the
restrictions and that's exactly what
we're gonna end up doing but I mean can
someone guess what a good polynomial
would be to make the rank measure
maximized here or make the gap
complexity Maximizer yeah sure yeah like
or yeah exactly right so I mean it's
pretty clear that the degree of or is n
right but then if I hit it with any one
of these restrictions it's obviously
going to simplify to a constant and so
it's going to drop to zero so the gap
for this so the algebraic a for this
formula we would say is in any sense
okay
well like I said a second ago if you
sort of line these things up like the
gap complexity looks a lot like the log
of the rank measure if you blur your
eyes and forget what degree and rank are
so it turns out that you can that you
can actually make this sort of formal
and the idea is you just compose using
the you know the the lifting theorem I
just showed you a second ago so start
with a polynomial that has a good
algebraic gap take your good gadget
write compose it and what you're going
to get is you're going to get a matrix
with really high rank because the degree
of the polynomial initially is large and
then you have to do some work to line
things up but what we want to do is line
up the certificates in the algebraic gap
with the sub rectangles of this matrix
right so it's a little bit of work to do
this but I mean you can do this and then
the next thing is that then the the rank
of the the rank of that sub-matrix it's
just going to be the you know it's going
to be defined by the degrees of the
polynomials under this restriction and I
just said that the degree of the
polynomial is going to you know simplify
a lot under every restriction so there
you go that's really clear I mean this
is a little bit hand wavy but maybe you
only sort of understand the idea so the
variables of your new problem are kind
of varying corresponds with the clauses
that's right that's right
and it makes sense if you think about
this this this this Sat problem I told
you before right the input if you think
about it as the input is specifying us
you know sets of clauses that's what the
underlined they're coming from the
underlying CNF formula right any other
questions
okay cool let me talk about the upper
band the upper band fortunately is a lot
easier like so but first I need to of
course to tell you what I know stone
South's reputation is yeah oh I see
yeah possibly yeah
so the original end of the log in lower
bounds by raspberr of are actually
proved by like a reduction to small set
disjointness ultimately and his
reduction is actually very similar it's
not phrased in this language at all but
the reduction is basically the same so
probably what's you could you could
phrase it in this way yeah but because
it but because it's a because
disjointness has large like co NP
complexity this it means you have to
focus on like small set just doing this
to make the number of variables not blow
up yeah maybe I can I can explain that a
bit more offline yeah so okay so me tell
you what it no stones that's reputation
is well it's pretty simple if I give you
some set of polynomials P 1 through P M
I know stolen sets reputation is just
another set of polynomials such that the
sum of the products is one right and and
what this tells you is that these
original polynomials right here they
don't have any common 0 right because if
there was some input on which they had a
common 0 that would simplify this to 0
but we would have 0 equals 1 so the
degree of an old stone sets reputation
is going to be the maximum degree of any
one of these products okay and we can
think of no spelling test as being like
a being like a propositional proof
system for refuting unsatisfiable CNS
just by taking unsatisfiable CNF and
sort of encoding them as polynomials and
some you know in sort of your favorite
way okay so here's like here's like the
standard way of doing it if here's a
really simple unsatisfiable CNF so for
every clause I'm just going to turn it
into a polynomial such that the clause
will be satisfied if and only if the
polynomial is 0 right so that way we
that way we can apply the nell stones
that sort of in the normal way so yeah
here i hopefully you convince yourself
that this is satisfied if
this is zero so the idea is you just
take your CNF supply the conversion
every clause and then also add in some X
I squared minus X I closet polynomials
to ensure that you know we're only
considering zero one solutions right and
of course if you you know you can like
multilinear eyes and kind of forget that
these are here but just for the sake of
the talk maybe like we can include them
okay so the no sound sets reputation of
C then it's just the minimum degree of a
no still in SATs refutation that works
okay so in order to lift no Stellan sets
that were so now we're trying to prove
the upper bound right so in order to
lift millstone sets to span program size
what I'll do is I'm going to introduce a
variant of span blicket like an
alternative definition this ban program
size introduced by an actually and a gal
which is very very very nice so here is
a communication complexity sort of
characterization to span program size so
here's our customer Vegas in matrix
again so let's just imagine blowing the
matrix apart into like its constituent
rectangles okay
so what I'm gonna do is for each one of
these rectangles just pick a mate pick
any matrix like before but such that the
only the nonzero entries of the
rectangle of the matrix are only going
to occur inside their rectangles that
make sense
so I'll call this I'll call such an
object in algebraic tiling if the sums
of all of these matrices is the all ones
matrix okay so it's kind of like a
tiling like if I had a regular tiling
like an actual tiling of the matrix then
I could just plug in the all one's
matrix and every single tile right and
then I would get you know the sum is all
one it's just telling me that every
entry is covered so this is kind of like
a generalization of this where I'm
allowing the tiles to overlap but I'm
keeping the constraint that this sum
algebraically has to be one so the size
of the algebraic tiling is then going to
be the sum of the sizes of the ranks of
the individual matrices okay so it turns
out that that the algebraic tiling
number so the size of the smallest
algebraic tiling is actually exactly the
same as monotone spanned program size
and it's it's
it this is a very very beautiful proof
and I'd like to highly recommend you go
look at it it's it's very very nice so
but this for our purposes it gives us
kind of a simple communication tool
ex-new measure to work with and once
again like before with the gap compared
to the rank measure just looking at this
you should think it also kind of looks a
lot like a no still incest refutation
right so like why is that well I mean if
we have a no spell intense refutation
and here I kind of you know abuse
notation just plugging in CI instead of
the polynomial itself so an algebraic
tiling on the other hand well an
algebraic tiling is just a sum of
matrices just that all the matrices is
exactly one and each AI is embedded in
some rectangle right whereas over here
we have the sum of the products is
exactly one now I can even make these
look even more the same right just by
placing an indicator for the rectangle
being multiplied say Hadamard y's right
here so you know and since that
complexity over here is the maximum
degree of the else telling tax
reputations and the complexity here is
the sum of the ranks it's natural to you
know take the dilemma I showed you a
second ago and just plug it in here and
it turns out exactly that works so all
we're going to do then is we're just
going to compose a null still in this
reputation with a good gadget so take
each of these guys and just plug in your
good gadget on either side automatically
we're gonna get that it's going to be
equal to one we know that you know we
know that we can control the ranks of
these things from the degrees of these
polynomials over here because the gadget
is good and so all you have to argue is
that you know what I'm actually getting
over here is a is an algebraic tiling
for like a real function and that again
is just sort of like some technical work
to push push stuff around but it's not
that bad it's just more or less goes by
what I showed you maybe 20 minutes ago
with the characterization of the lifted
search problem does that make sense
okay so got a minutes left I thought I
was gonna I thought I was gonna go long
so I actually I didn't even think I was
going to get here
so my I'll tell you what my original
thing was but now maybe I can actually
tell you a bit more about it on the
board so my original think claim was to
just go see the paper if you wanted to
see the duality theorem but um maybe I
can actually sort of a sketch a little
bit on the board with the ten minutes I
have left does that sound good
okay
so okay so obviously once we have this
equality the whole this makes everything
tick right like we can just sort of
everything was a little simplify and
we'll get sort of the characterization
up to the we you know the constant
exponent so what's the intuition behind
this
well let's recall with the gap and the
nullstellensatz look like so the gap of
F at C say at a polynomial P so P of
course is degree in and it's multilinear
this is just going to be n minus the
maximum over all the certificates of P
of C sorry
the degree at the restriction yeah we're
talking about general assistance of
polynomials would it make sense to
replace the degree of restriction with
the degree of D mod Q I yeah yeah you
can talk about that I and I don't think
a characterize there's no strolling
sense anymore yeah I tried that I I it
yeah I just algebraically doesn't really
work out yeah good question though its I
I try for quite a while to try and see
if you could do this for our retreat
polynomials but it seems that the fact
that things are melting linear is
somehow very important here okay so ya
know still in SATs degree of C I'm just
gonna write like the sum of zi x qi
right like an all still intact it's just
no sells its reputation is it looks like
this and then this is going to be the
maximum
I in him have the degree of the product
okay all right well so I claim that one
of these directions is actually very
easy and it mmm it basically just
follows from the the upper bound
argument that the span program size is
lower bounded by the ranked measure okay
so so how does it work well suppose I
actually had one of these notes telling
sense refutations right here okay
some see i q-- i equals 1 and then let's
pick out let's just pick a polynomial P
for this gap so if you multiply P on
both sides
all right I'm just gonna get something
like this okay
I'm gonna just multi linearize
everything so I don't have to worry
about the x squared minus X constraints
because those are just a pain all right
so let's just do this and let's just
take the degree okay of each side so
what are we gonna get well all you get
is that see I times P I do I equals well
let's say the degree okay should be P
thanks so I'm just gonna fold that in
and then just take the degree on both
sides so this on this side is definitely
gonna be n okay and then over here well
the degree of the sum is going to be the
maximum degree of any one of the
individual guys right okay so
right so I mean that now we're done
right because all we get because like
what's happening right here
well like that's exactly right
yeah this is just P restricted by that
guy right there right so now you know
there should be a degree here so now you
know the degree of the product is the
sum of the degrees I can just drag this
degree over here and then I get what's
left over here just gonna be the degree
of this product right here okay so that
direction is actually very easy so me
since okay so the other direction
follows just by this sort of alternative
characterization of no Stellan test
degree in terms of designs and the
reason basically if you're familiar with
what with what a design is the reason
that this works is that the algebraic
gap is just a design but written in a
different in the polynomial basis
instead of as a instead of as a linear
functional so well okay so a design is
sort of the classic way of proving
you'll still in SATs lower bounds so if
I haven't suppose I have a know still in
sense refutation and I want to argue
that it has large degree like any
nullstellensatz reputation of this of
this set of this you know CNF has large
degree so the natural thing to do is to
it turns out is to come up with sort of
a linear functional and all the linear
functional is going to do is it's going
to map you know all the low degree
polynomials that are in the ideal
generated by the CIS to 0 and it's going
to map one to one right so so L when
you're functional
so people are from there with SOS this
should look very familiar
so I'm just gonna so it's just gonna
enforce that you know one is map-21
and I'll just say because I'd only have
like five minutes left that L of let's
call it R where R is sort of um you know
like any idea narrated here like it's
just like from multiplications of low
degree multiplications of CI is 0 so
ours from say low degree ideal generated
any sense so clearly if such an object
exists then just applying it to any
candidate low degree no stolen tax
refutation would show that it's not
actually a no still on tax refutation
right so now what I claim is that if you
a linear functional is just exactly the
same as the thing P which witnesses your
algebraic gap
so you have to squint and turn sideways
a bit so this is actually like an
isomorphism I guess so why is that well
just take your linear functional and
instead of writing it over you know
instead of imagining as a function we'll
take it in like the dual basis just
write it down as a polynomial and then
finally invert everything so map the
high degree elements of your functional
to the low degree elements just like
flip it upside down so this will convert
this constraint L of 1 equals 1
after taking the dual basis and flipping
it we'll just get that the degree of the
corresponding functional is n that's
exactly the first constraint right here
so then the second constraint is this
thing which just says that all the
polynomials have to cancel out well if
you actually go in and look at what a
polynomial generated in this ideal is
when you write it in the dual basis it's
just exactly the certificate canceling
property right so saying that this is
always going to be 0 after I do the flip
it's just the same as saying that the
degree is going to be low after I hit it
with all the restrictions by dual basis
you're replacing each product by the
product of all the term the monomial by
the product of all the terms
oh no no because you're not over +1 but
anyway you want to yeah dividing the
monomial into the product of all the
terms yeah like just imagine like
writing down all the monomials like in
the sum and just like decorating the
coefficients with the values here except
I'm gonna flip them yeah right so I'll
replace we're Diplomat pen third so I'll
replace them so if I have a monomial say
product of X I for I and s the
coefficient here isn't going to be like
the natural thing to put there is going
to be L of s but in order to get this
this this thing to work I'm gonna put in
L of n minus s
so I thought I mean I flip them right so
now hopefully it should be clear like
this L of one is one just means that
this will have degree n and then you
know you just have to do some linear
algebra to work out that actually this
constraint just corresponds to the
certificate killing constraint okay so
that's everything that's it that's
everything so let me start include some
open problems
so one bummer about this is that it only
works for in the worst case setting and
like ah so average case monotone circuit
lower bounds are actually like extremely
interesting and in particular over like
the uniform distribution because
everyone in this room certainly knows
that if I get monotone circuit lower
bounds at the slice then this is just
proving non monotone circuit lower
balanced right so it's obviously of
interest to try and push the the min
terms and Max term sizes as close to the
slice as possible and average-case
bounds over the uniform distribution are
just exactly this right like they're
sort of an average case version of this
so to be nice to sort of try and take
these lifting theorems that we have
these techniques and try and convert
them into into reasonable average case
lower bounds over good distributions not
over weird minterm accent distributions
that you get so a second thing is that
I'd like to actually separate the rank
measure in the algebraic tiling number
so there's this classic result by
raspberr of which says in the non
monotone case this can't give you any
lower bounds this rank measure is always
at most order M so in fact you can show
that in the non monotone case the rank
measure is always at most a decision
tree complexity which is funny because
in the non monotone world this decision
tree complexity and in the non monotone
world that gets you like tight lower
bounds right so it's even though even
though we have like an like like a nice
characterization right here it would be
nice to find like some like some
reasonable separation it's not going to
work for these lifted functions
obviously because for lifted functions
we know they're the same but we like you
don't actually come up with like I like
a really a brand new technique outside
of looking theorems in order to prove
this kind of thing and finally the
question that I also think is very
interesting is to try and operationalize
the rank measure so what do I mean by
that I mean that if you if you go back
and you look at this algebraic
Eiling thing so like let's suppose that
we were in a world where we discovered
algebraic pilings first right would we
have discovered span programs like I
don't know like you know it like like
the the reduction from span programs
algebraic tilings is is like it's it's
very it's it's beautiful but it's sort
of it's it's in depth like it's not
natural to see how to go from algebra
like it's not just from the definition
of an algebraic tiling it's not natural
to go from one to the other so perhaps
all of these communication complexity
measures which don't currently
correspond to circuit models actually do
correspond to circuit models in some
sense so is there some way to sort of
systematize this and come up with you
know a generic way of converting back
and forth and yeah so let me let me plug
Micah's talk one more time because in
some settings were actually able to do
this sort of thing and yeah that's it
Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's thank him again and resume it
11:30
[Applause]